c'est normal ça normal de d'entreprendre
un tour de france
au moment des régionales qui ont des
actes de campagne qui normalement ne pas
avoir mieux en cette période
[Musique]
il est quelque part en campagne
je suis pour la chienne cours pour les
régionales il y a le droit de réserve
si j'applique s'applique au ministère
applique au gouvernement bien entendu
que dans les textes
peut-être que le président n'ait pas
nommé mais déontologiquement ça
s'applique au chef de l'état qui lui a
nommé son gouvernement
[Musique]
gia démons zone antilles on ne prend pas
ce une grande place dans l'espace
politique français et qui n'ont pas la
parole à la hauteur de leur implantation
cette raclée
[Musique]
merci je t'aime il perd présidentielle
et quand on a la majorité derrière on
fait ce qu'on veut